right then it's nine o'clock so we can
kick off
thank you so much for coming here it is
a joy to see your happy shining faces
after two years of not being able to do
this kind of thing so i'm really excited
uh to to see you all and and to get back
into this um so my name is steve and i
work at microsoft i'm on the asp.net
team and one of my main focuses is this
thing blazer which i'm going to be here
to talk to you about today particularly
about stuff that we've been doing in.net
6 and maybe some slightly further ahead
things than that so
blazer is a ui framework for net for
building web-based uis if you didn't
already know um and it's going really
well as a project it's one of the
fastest growing parts of net and we've
done a lot of work on it in net six
we've shipped an absolute mountain of
new features uh here's a sampling of
many of them now obviously i do not have
time in this talk to go through each of
these one by one also it would be boring
um so what we're gonna do in this talk
is
focus on a specific business scenario
and go through the process of working
out which of these new features would
actually be useful in solving some of
the business requirements in this
scenario so it's not going to be
representative of everything in blazer
it's just going to be a specific set of
things that are new and hopefully
interesting and on this same theme so
we'll focus on stuff that is new in net
six
and uh hopefully it will inspire you to
think about some potentially new kinds
of application capabilities that you
could create that you wouldn't have done
before on.net 5.
now we'll also talk a bit about some of
the work we've done and performance for
webassembly and then at the end i'll
talk about some other experiments that
are you know not stuff that we've
shipped or even committed to ship but
are just thinking about at the moment
okay so we're gonna need a specific
application scenario i don't really like
to just do basic hello world kind of
demos so let's imagine a kind of
business okay so i don't know if you
know this but as well as being on the
asp.net team i'm also
a reclusive eccentric billionaire and i
was chatting to some of my billionaire
friends lately and it turns out they've
all got their own space agencies and i
felt a bit envious of that so i called
up my people and i said hey can we have
a space agency please and they set one
up for me and i decided to call it
blazorbital
um and this is great news for you
because i want you to come and work at
this company and be one of the chief
software architects and i know this is
big news to you because you thought
you'd already got a job and a family and
stuff but you're gonna relocate okay
um you've probably got a lot of
questions
chief question i would think is what
technologies do you use at this company
so i will give you a quick overview all
right
so at this company we've got a set of
central servers which manage all the
critical business data and our auth that
kind of thing and it just so happens to
be written with asp.net core but doesn't
really matter for the purposes of this
talk
then there's various other departments
in the business that you'll need to know
about and work with there's the
manufacturing group okay these people
design and manufacture rockets and
manage warehouses that kind of thing and
they've got a front end implemented with
blazerwebassemblyon.net five so you
might want to update that um and that
communicates to the central server over
a secure grpc channel then there's
another group the missions team they
deal with people are actually in space
tracking satellites that kind of thing
and they've got a front end implemented
in react so it's just a different team
they've made a different technology
choice that's how it is in the world
okay and then there's a third group
might not seem quite as cool but it's
sort of important if you like getting
paid that's the accounting team and they
have got a native windows wpf desktop
application it might be a bit legacy but
you know that's how things are and again
it connects to the same central servers
and then finally i almost forgot there's
a team called the libraries team they
produce shared code that everyone else
uses and for their own mysterious
reasons they will only work in rust so
you're going to have to deal with that
whether or not that's convenient to you
okay so you are going to be working on
the manufacturing hub part of our
software suite which is the blazer
webassembly application
so let's imagine that you take this job
all right and you've been working on it
for like a year or something like that
you've been having a good time the
technology is good you've got incredible
ceo so you're like you're pretty happy
um but one day i come to you and i say
hey i've got a new business requirement
for you okay we've been having some
trouble in the warehouses knowing what's
in stock and where it is and how much it
should be billed for and things like
that so i need you to create a new
inventory management system and i've got
some requirements for you
firstly it needs to support some very
fast and powerful querying so we can
quickly see what's where all right
but while you're doing that you are not
allowed to put any new heavy load on the
central servers because they are already
busy enough
right
now thirdly this is a space agency so we
need to tolerate failures uh network
connection could go down during a
mission and you need your application to
keep on working including the querying
uh even if the network is down okay
fourthly
i don't just want to see this in the
blazer application we also need this in
the react application and in the wpf
application i've no idea how you're
going to do that but you're the
developer so you go and figure out out
please and then finally
we need to print out these shipping
labels in the warehouses but don't worry
the rust team has already created a
library for generating qr codes so
please integrate that into your software
again i don't know how you're going to
use rust you figure it out all right
so those are your requirements
so
let's have a go at doing some of that
and we'll see if some of the new
features in dot net six will help you
deliver on your goals so let's switch
over to visual studio and i've got a
fairly predictable kind of solution here
where i've got the central server and
some other projects and i've got my
manufacturing hub application we'll just
start that in a browser and see how it
looks before we start getting into any
code okay so it's a pretty
typical kind of blazer webassembly
application this is and of course you're
gonna have to log in because the central
server won't talk to you if you don't
give it any auth tokens so let's log in
like that
and now we're logged in we can access
some data on the central server which
has given us these statistics about
stuff that's happening in the warehouse
okay so that's all very well but we
don't actually care about any of that
right now what we care about is this
inventory screen over here
so this is where we're going to build
the new warehouse management ui
and remember we need to be able to have
fast powerful querying that works
offline and doesn't put load on the
server so we're going to need some kind
of client-side offline capable database
now wouldn't it be nice if we could use
the leading tool for working with
relational databases on.net core which
is entity framework core and wouldn't it
be nice if the database behind that was
something robust and industry standard
and battle tested like sql lite well
you could try and do that on
blazerwebassembly.net5 and it would not
work and i will show you why it will not
work okay let's have a look at a little
bit of code
so here is the uh component that we were
just looking at there the inventory page
okay so i've got a bit of code in here
already which is going to try and use
efcor so first it's going to create a
database context that defines the shape
of the database and it says that we're
going to use sqlite as the underlying
backend and then we've got some code
that will try to create a database with
ensure created async we're going to
insert a new row into it and finally
we'll do a query to see if we can get
all that data back now don't worry if
you can't read this in time or don't
understand it but you get the basic idea
we're going to create a database and try
and use it all right let's see if it
actually works and it won't so when i
click on this button
what do we get we get an unhandled error
has occurred well why let's have a look
we'll look in the console and we'll see
the underlying reason for the error is
this dll not found e-sqlite3
well
this makes sense actually because sqlite
is native code it's written with c
and
although you can compile it into a dll
you can't load random dlls into a web
browser you know the browser sandbox
webassembly does not allow you to load
random native code like that so it's not
going to work um but a feature that we
are adding in net 6 called native
dependencies means that we can overcome
this problem so with dot net 6 if you
can compile something to webassembly you
can now link it in with your laser
webassembly application and then call it
like any other native library so let's
see if we can make sqlite three uh
sqlite work for us
so we're gonna have to try and compile
it to webassembly and i've got over here
the source code for sqlite3 which is one
giant c file believe it or not that is
how they distribute it which is
fantastic it's such an easy way of
making it portable across different
operating systems and different
compilation systems so i'm going to
compile that
using the
uh and script and c compiler here i'm
going to compile that to a shared
library called e sqlite3 whose name
might be familiar to you from this
previous error message over here all
right so if we have a look again in this
directory you'll see we've now got e
sqlite 3.0 which actually contains
webassembly by code and we're going to
link that into our application so let's
go to the project file here
and
don't pay attention to the rest of it
because it's just more stuff that you
can read and understand the important
point here is we're referencing the
entity framework core sqlite package and
next to this although i could put it
anywhere i'm going to put this new thing
called native file reference okay and
that is telling the compiler that i want
to include this e sqlite 3.0 file that
we've built in the compiled application
right now because i've done that the
next time i build it takes a little bit
longer to build because it sees that the
native dependencies have changed and it
has to re-link stuff and re-optimize and
so on um but when it's done that the
application will reload and let us see
what happens when we click the button
this time do we get an error this time
the answer is no we do not get an error
it now actually works it now really uses
ef core inside the browser really has an
actual sqlite database so that opens up
some interesting new possibilities for
us
so
let's imagine that you do a few more
days of work now based on this new power
and you write some code that is going to
fetch data from the central servers and
synchronize it into this client-side
database and you start working on a
little bit of a grid ui to display it as
well now we don't have time to go
through that step by step so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to just jump
forwards in time slightly to the point
where you've got a basic version of this
already okay so i'm going to hit save on
that and the first thing we'll notice is
that the hot reload system
jumps up and says hey looks like you
changed your code there but you made so
many changes i can't hot reload that now
we'll have a look at hot reload in a
minute but when we've made this many
changes i'm just going to say all right
fine you can just restart my application
for me because i've made all these
changes so that's going to restart now
and when it does you'll see it starts
doing some slightly more interesting
stuff
so it's now fetching this data from the
back end and synchronizing it into this
client-side database and displaying it
in a little grid uh you can find all the
source code for this on github i'll give
you the link to it later on um but the
stuff i really want to to emphasize to
you is uh that this is a virtualized
grid so even though we're working with
quite a lot of data here we've got 100
000 items in here i can still just
instantly scroll to any part of that
list that i want to it's as if the data
is already there in the browser because
it is it's inside the sqlite database so
we can just query it locally and put it
into this virtualized ui instantly even
with very large volumes of data
okay that's good
now then let's have a go at making some
other changes to our code and i'm going
to just reorganize the screen a little
bit
so we can experience a bit of hot reload
uh while we work on this code
so
i'm not very happy with the way this
price is displayed actually let me just
uh change the scroll position and sort
order like that right so i'm not super
happy with this because these numbers
like this number here that's just mad
what is that
let's change the formatting a little bit
so
i have got this um
template column here uh and i can make
some changes to it and hopefully when i
make changes they will automatically
show up in the browser okay so i'm going
to say firstly let's uh display this
with currency formatting okay so
using.net's currency formatting uh
feature i'm going to press save on that
and when i do hot reload kicks in and
you'll see it now instantly starts
changing to show this stuff in british
pounds but we haven't lost the scroll um
position or the saw order or anything
like that it's all just retained um so
that's good but it's also wrong because
these are meant to be the price in cents
and yeah i'm saying they're pounds
that's that's pretty weird so let's
change that i'm going to get rid of this
and i'm going to pretend that they're
dollars so i'm going to put a dollar
sign at the start there and we'll save
and then that updates that's nice but
it's still wrong because these are the
price in cents and not dollars so let's
divide that by 100 hit save again and
that makes slightly more sense now
but i still want to format it a bit
better than that i would like to i want
it to have comma separators in between
the different groups so i'm going to say
i'll do that to string as a number with
zero decimal places i'll hit save and
again it updates and the formatting
starts to make a bit of sense now that's
good
um but i'm still not happy i don't
really want to have this dollar sign on
every single row so let's take that out
from there just to show we can change
more stuff than a bit of static template
like that and we'll change this
parameter and you'll see that that does
indeed update up there
and since this is a number i'm going to
right align it so let's do that and
that's going to work as well
and we could make more changes still for
example let's say i don't want the
the columns to be in this order i want
the name column to be first not id well
i'm just going to swap the order of
these lines in my editor press save and
they will of course swap around again
and maybe i don't actually want to
display the id anyway because what
what's the use of that that's just some
technical detail let's display this
stock level in stock like that
and i will display the stock level all
right so i'm going to hit save on that
and again that's going to update
all right so we are having a pretty good
fluid development experience thanks to
the hot reload system uh all of these
changes that we've been making we did
not lose the state of our application
as for what changes you can make without
losing your state well it it varies uh
there are many kinds of changes that
will be applied without losing any state
there are some changes that can't be
applied and when that happens it will
automatically restart your page for you
but hopefully you have a pretty fluid
experience with that
now let's look at this file a little bit
more broadly because there's more stuff
going on in here and i appreciate i
haven't shown you all this code and you
won't know what it all is but let's just
try and spot a few new.net six features
in here so looking down from the top the
first new dot net six feature is this
thing page title okay so this is a on a
slightly tangential topic really but um
one of the new features is that you see
this title up here where it says
inventory well if i navigate to another
page well that title is going to change
and if i navigate back then it's going
to change back so that's just
another feature of.net 6. easy way of
changing the page title um the sing
status thing that's some code that i
wrote that displays the progress bar
that you saw a minute ago
there's nothing new in there you can see
the code for this later if you want to
uh what else have we got well the actual
logic for the component is this when
it's initialized it's going to get an
entity framework db context that gives
us access to the local sqlite database
and we'll subscribe for notifications
when that changes so we can update the
ui and then finally we've got the grid
and you've already seen some of that now
the grid is another thing whose sources
in this project you can see later if you
want so this is cool we could build a
quite sophisticated ui with this so
again let's pretend that you do a couple
days more work and you add some more
columns and you add some filtering
capabilities so once again let's jump
forwards in time slightly to a more
updated version of this code and i'll
hit save and again uh because i've made
so many changes the hot reload system is
going to have to restart the page just
there and when that comes back you'll
see there's more stuff going on now so
we've got more columns we've got
filtering i can do things like
multi-select to
to you know show more to filter on
categories and subcategories that's
another new.net six feature by the way
if you bind to an array then that
automatically works with multi-selection
didn't before but it does now uh what
else have we got we've got something
like uh filtering as we search let's
as i type then you see that that just
updates i'll show you how that works in
a minute and then finally what about
filtering by stock level i've got these
sliders and as i move the slider what
happens oh nothing happens nothing
whatsoever what's going on have we got a
bug in the code
well no i deliberately just didn't
implement this because i wanted to show
you how it's implemented to give you a
bit more of a sense of what's going on
here
so how does this work and or why does it
not work well let's have a look at the
source code well what we've got now uh
inside our markup here inside this stock
column we've got some options for that
and we've got these html range sliders
and that uses normal blazer syntax to
bind the value of this slider to a c
sharp field called min stock all right
what's that well that is defined down
here i've got min stock and mac stock
that have got particular default values
and we want to include those values in
the query that we do against the sqlite
database where is that query defined
well it's defined here as this big
property
and you can see it uses a standard
iqueryable which is the the net way of
building up a query and then that can be
translated automatically by ef core into
a sql query that hopefully will be
reasonably efficient and we can use
normal procedural logic to build up that
query and you see we're including the
category subcategory and name but we
have not included the stock level so
it's that's why it's ignoring the stock
level so let's put in the logic for that
right so let's just paste that in if
you've given us a stock level then we'll
have a where clause for the min stock
and maybe for the max stock as well all
right let's see if that actually works
then shall we we'll go back into our
browser here and now if i move these
range sliders here you'll see that the
querying happens in real time while i
move the slider if you see that number
in the bottom left see how that's
changing as i move it and this is a
pretty awesome developer user experience
actually you don't normally see this
kind of thing on the web because it
would normally be impractical to be you
know hitting the server with queries at
60 frames a second but when you've got a
client-side single user database you can
just do this kind of thing it's fine
like the performance is going to be fine
because the worst thing that can happen
is that one user slows themselves down
they can't slow anyone else down by
issuing too many queries so you know you
can do this kind of thing which is
pretty cool
all right so let's recap where we are
on our
on our roadmap here we've implemented
some fast and powerful querying and
we've done so without putting any heavy
load on the server because we're just
synchronizing changes from the server
and after that we don't even talk to it
okay so that's pretty good
right then what about these other things
let's start with that one at the bottom
the qr code from the rust team
what's that where's that going to go and
how are we going to use it well let's uh
open up one of these things let's open
up this support ramp which sounds very
exciting um this is the stock label that
people need to be able to print out and
you can see it's got this gray box in it
and that's where we want to display a qr
code right so let's see i've actually
started working on a component that
displays qr codes already this is a
normal blazer component and it wants to
display stuff using an html canvas where
it can paint the qr code and it's going
to get that qr code by making a call
into this function called generate qr
code which itself is being imported from
a dll called lib rust qr so i think
hopefully you'll get a sense of how this
is going to fit together now we're going
to write a bit of rus code that creates
a dll and then we're going to link this
in with our blazer webassembly
application and then we'll be able to
call rust code directly from our.net
code
now in fact i've already done that so
i'm just going to uncomment this line
and you'll see it happen so let's just
move this over here and this over here
and uh yeah that's good enough all right
so when i uncomment this and i press
save hot reload will happen and you can
see it now actually does call into this
rust library and a qr code shows up
which is cool um but how does it work
and why is it blue that's pretty weird
isn't it qr codes aren't normally blue
so i just want to use that as an excuse
to show you the russ code basically um
and we're going to fix this entirely
artificial bug in the rust code
so here is my rust library or the rust
teams library and how does it work well
if you don't know russcode obviously
it's going to look a bit unfamiliar to
you but don't worry about that it's
pretty straightforward all it's doing is
it's taking this value in from.net and
it's calling out to a third-party rust
package or crate as they call it called
qr code to generate a qr code that
encodes that value and then all the
remaining code down here which there's
not very much of all that is doing is
just changing the order of the pixels
because in
an html canvas you must have rgba format
pixels and that's not what the rust
crate produces so we have to change the
order of all those pixels and that and
that's what this is for but there is a
bug and it is on this line of code here
you'll see that the blue channel is
hard-coded to be 255 which is always on
uh regardless of whether this pixel
should be on or off so that's why it's
coming out in blue and it's pretty
obvious that we can fix that by making
the pixel the blue channel vary
according to the uh the pixel value okay
so i've made that change i'm going to
rebuild it using cargo build that's the
standard rust tool chain it's insanely
fast and that is natively producing some
web assembly by code for me okay so we
want to have that in our blazer
application in fact we already do let me
just show you here we've got um this
native reference here which is the same
as the way that we pulled in the sqlite
binary before this time we're pulling in
the rust
binary which has been compiled to
webassembly so hopefully when that
finishes redoing all the native linking
it's going to restart our application
and then we should see the changes being
applied uh based on the change we just
made to the rust code
okay so here that comes back and now
we'll go into here and you'll see it now
comes up in black and we've fixed our
book so it really was running the rust
code
cool that's nice now what about making
it work offline
well in a sense there might not be very
much work for us to do here because
we've already got a local database which
doesn't need a server and blazer
webassembly has always supported working
offline as a pwa so maybe it's just
gonna work maybe if we just publish it
as a pwa it's gonna work so i'm gonna i
have published it as a pwa already and
i've just launched it from my windows
taskbar and you see it comes up in its
own window and it's looking the same as
it does when it's in a browser it's got
all the same functionality and filtering
and stuff great but what about being
offline
well to simulate that i'm going to kill
the web server completely so here is the
web server for central server and now it
is dead right so if i start this again
it obviously can't talk to the web
server because there isn't one um it's
simulating a severed network connection
so it takes a little longer to start up
now because it's trying to talk to the
server and it can't so after a little
bit it's going to give up and we can
write whatever kind of user experience
we want around that so we can say sorry
there's a problem if we want we can tell
people what the problem was but they can
still use the application they can still
navigate over to inventory and we can
still give them access to all the data
that's already available locally and all
the same filtering and stuff is still
going to work our code knows it can't
talk to the server so we can still have
a user experience around that but
basically it's going to work as well as
could be possible under the
circumstances
so
we've got it working offline as well
right now time for something a bit more
challenging what about using it in these
other apps the react app and the wpf app
how on earth are we going to do that
well let's start by thinking about this
react application actually for mission
control i'm going to show you that
so let's go over to this mission control
application here which i've got in vs
code this is a react application there's
nothing react specific about this by the
way be the same for angular view or html
whatever you want okay i'm going to
start this up in a web browser and this
is our mission control application this
is where we track the position of
satellites we track how long it's been
since we last saw any aliens that kind
of normal stuff okay
and of course it's going to require us
to log in because otherwise the central
server will not give us any data it's
going to use the same single sign-on
system so i don't have to type my
password i just become logged in based
on my existing cookies all right now we
don't really care about all this stuff
what we care about is the equipment
finder alright this is where we want to
put the inventory grid that we just
implemented in blazer but how on earth
are we going to do that in a react
application well
let's have a look shall we let's see how
this um
application looks in the first place the
react source code so i've got this
equipment finder js file and let's get a
bit more space on the screen all right
then
so if you know react you'll see this is
pretty basic stuff and if you don't well
just trust me it's pretty basic um the
only thing that this is doing is keeping
track of some text that's typed into
this search box all right so that's what
this search text up here is going to be
and then the rest of it is just
displaying some static html
and we want to put the inventory grid
right here how could we do it well
one way we could do it which would be
kind of rubbish but it would sort of
work is that we could put an iframe in
here and an iframe could host the blazer
webassembly application it would work
it's very old-school way of approaching
this um but it would be kind of rubbish
because it would be a completely
separate universe it wouldn't uh share
any auth state it wouldn't share any
styling it'd be really hard to get
parameters in and out
so wouldn't it be nice if instead of
that we could just somehow use our
inventory grid as if it was a normal
html element that would be cool wouldn't
it well one of the new features of dot
net 6 is that you can if you want to do
exactly that so i'm going to show you
how this is enabled if i go into my
program cs file here and scroll down to
the bottom you can see we're calling
this api i'm taking the inventory
component that we implemented earlier
and registering it as a custom element
called inventory grid so custom elements
are part of the web component spec and
this means it looks and feels like a
normal html element and you can just use
that in your angular react view or plain
html website whatever you've got okay so
let's have a go at trying to do that
i've already added the necessary script
tag to this page that will load the
blazer webassembly code so hopefully i
can just add an inventory grid right
here and then i'm going to press save
and the react hot reload system will
happen and our blazer uh component will
show up as if it's just a normal html
element and it will have all the same
functionality that we had before um if
you're wondering why it has to fetch all
the data again well it's because this is
a different website it doesn't share any
storage with the other one you know it's
a different origin
so it's a completely separate uh world
as far as the data is concerned
but it's gonna work and we've got all
the same functionality um one thing i'm
not too happy with here though
is the visual styling
because everything else in mission
control uses a dark theme but this is a
light theme and it's kind of a bit
clashing and out of place um but the
good news is since this is not an iframe
it's going to use the same css styles as
the host page so i can use react styling
system here
i'm going to go into this css file and
i'll say i want to find the table that's
in my inventory grid and apply a css
filter to invert that
and press save and boom instant dark
mode and now we are on theme for the
mission control application that's good
um
but one the other thing is still not
working
you see this thing where i'm typing
search criteria in it's just not doing
anything why is that well because i'm
not passing that criteria into the dot
net code yet now inside the inventory
grid if you look in the uh
the
blazer code we've got a parameter called
search name which we can pass in and
that is translated in this api to an
html attribute so i can pass
search name in here and what value
should we give to it well we'll give the
value that you've typed into your text
box so i'll press save and now again the
hot reload system happens and our query
is applied and just instantly now as we
type
that will be applied directly from the
react text box into the blazer
application
cool pretty good now i don't know if
you've noticed but we've been using the
react hot reload system there and it's
retained the state of the react
application as we did that it's also
retained the state of the dot net
application as we did that so that's
pretty neat
but what would happen if we changed the
net code would the hot reload system for
dot network in this environment well
let's try it shall we um so what are we
going to change well it's a bit
arbitrary but let's just change this
column title just for the sake of
changing something i'm going to change
it from category to cat's name just you
know to change something and i'll press
save on that and get a strange message
but nonetheless you'll see that the hot
reload system has actually worked so the
dot net hot reload has worked inside
this react application preserving the
state of both the dot net code and the
react code as well as the react hot
reload system also working together in
one application which hopefully means
that you can be pretty spectacularly
productive and and i can give you a
promotion and we're all happy
all right
so we've got our blazer code running
inside a react application that's nice
but what about putting it in a wpf app
is that even harder maybe because with
react at least it's running in a browser
but wpf it's not even a web browser how
on earth are we going to display
a blazer component in that well let me
show you uh in fact i've already got
this working and i'm just going to show
you that it's working
so i'm going to set this accounting
application as my starter project and
run it and this is going to use a
feature that we haven't actually shipped
in.net 6 yet so i'm cheating a little
bit here but as part of the maui release
next year we are creating the ability to
uh host blazer components inside native
desktop and mobile applications for
windows mac ios android and also for wpf
and winforms so here's a wpf application
it's got all this boring accounting
stuff in it but when i move over onto
the inventory page what are we going to
see
well we're going to see our blazer
component the first thing it's going to
demand that i log in because you know
again the central server won't talk to
us otherwise uh but once i've done that
exactly the same stuff is going to work
as we had before and this is really the
same code literally the same thing where
we just changed cat name a minute ago is
right there inside our wpf application
and it's got exactly the same
functionality now how does that work
well the api for embedding a blazer
component is going to be different
depending on whether you're doing
winforms wpf or maui
in the wpf case which i don't know
whether you care about or not uh but let
me just show you anyway uh wfpf is based
around xaml so excuse me we've got uh
xaml api for that and it looks a bit
like this so we've got this blazer
webview and what that's going to do is
create a small web browser
instance that lives as part of the wpf
control hierarchy and then it's able to
insert one of our blazer components
in this case we're inserting the
inventory one
and if you're wondering is this web
assembly or is this blazer server the
answer is no neither it this is just
blazer okay it's running your blazer
component directly on the native.net
runtime within this application not
webassembly not server it's just
blazeron.net okay so it's a relatively
simple and highly performant system and
one last thing if i click on one of
these you'll see this qr code comes up
now that might be a bit baffling at
first because remember we compiled the
rust code to webassembly and this is not
webassembly this application so how is
this rust code working inside blazer
inside wpf well the answer to that is
if you've got a native library you need
to compile it to each of the native
platforms you want to support
and in this case i've compiled the
libros qr both to webassembly and to a
native windows binary and so when we use
an api
like this dll import it's going to work
the same everywhere this is an important
thing to illustrate that we want the
programming experience to be the same
whether you're doing webassembly server
maui anything else if you're using
something even an advanced feature like
dll import it should work the same and
do the right thing on each platform that
you're running on
all right so
we've completed all of our goals and we
can go home for the weekend and feel
good about ourselves um but
let's change the subject a little bit
and think now about performance
okay we've not really thought about that
in this talk so far uh this is an area
that we've done a lot of investment in
in dot net six um i don't know if you
know this but
dot net on webassembly up until now in
dot net 5 and earlier has always been
running on an interpreter the dot net
runtime uh is
an interpreter for for dot net runtime
when we compile the dot net runtime for
webassembly it is an interpreter that's
all i'm saying here
and that's great for your productivity
and for small app sizes but it's not
always great for performance on cpu
bound code and that is why we've created
ahead of time compilation for this which
can hopefully improve the performance
and i'm going to give you a quick
demonstration of that a visual
demonstration even though it's kind of a
silly scenario okay so
our uh crazy scenario is that we found a
wormhole into a binary star system and
we want to send some satellites in to
research the this
uh you know binary star system so our
scientists have created a simulation of
satellites moving inside a binary star
system here
and they've chosen to do that on blazer
webassembly which is a wildly
inappropriate thing to do but they've
done that anyway okay and the only thing
that you actually need to
care about here is the fact that this
all of this physics stuff here is
actually c sharp code it is.now and i'll
actually let me just show you i'm not
going to go through it line by line a
wrong file
it's in here all right so it's super
basic we've got a body which has got a
position velocity mass and color all
right we can make it go to a random
place we've got the satellites and some
suns we give them an initial position
on every frame here 60 frames a second
we're going to run the physics for the
sun's and for all of the bodies all
right and what does it mean to run
physics well we'll loop over all the
suns we'll work out the acceleration
using some basic like high school
newtonian physics and update the
velocity we'll update the position and
if it's gone too far away we'll respawn
it all right so it's basic basic stuff
and you just need to understand that
it's written in c sharp okay so this is
an actual measure of the performance of
our c sharp code how many satellites can
we get
well we've got 100 in here could we have
a 200 satellites
yes we could could we have 500
yes we could and it's 60 frames a second
okay that's great
could we manage a thousand satellites
yes
2 000
yes 4 000
yes
six thousand
yeah no okay so it's gone down to less
than 60 frames a second it's near oh
okay we can just about do six thousand
seven thousand no all right so this is
not aot compiled code this is running on
the interpreter which is you know
reasonably fast and if you're just
building grids and stuff it's easily
fast enough but if you're going to do
some c some high performance cpu band
code then you might encounter
bottlenecks how much faster would this
get if we compiled it to uh with aot
compilation well i've got that same code
absolutely identical here compiled and
published with aot compilation here and
i'm going to run that just the same as
we did before now we know of course we
can get a thousand or five thousand
because we just did that on the
interpreter
could we have ten thousand
yes
uh how about twenty thousand yep
forty thousand
yeah uh fifty thousand
uh yes
uh seventy thousand
no not really it's now oh sort of still
doing yeah eighty 000 i don't know
around this point we're going to run out
of steam uh and you know we've seen the
limits here but this is a pretty amazing
improvement it's kind of a 10x
improvement over what we had on the
interpreter so to
to illustrate this a little bit more
precisely i want to give you some
numbers now
so i ran some tests earlier on i had a
higher screen resolution at the time so
there were smaller numbers of satellites
uh so in debug mode i was getting about
four and a half thousand satellites when
i compile this with a release build
which is still on the interpreter but
it's more optimized i was getting you
know good improvement kind of three
times faster there in release build
when i did an aot build it went up to a
massive 58 000 satellites so that's kind
of a 10 times gain and you will
generally see this kind of massive
improvement if your code is cpu bound
but not if it's bound on something else
obviously if it's bound on network speed
or the rate of user input or something
obviously it's not users won't type 10
times faster because you've done iot
type uh code but um it will hopefully
make your cpu bound code faster however
there is a cost to doing this and i want
to make sure you understand that cost
because i'm all about giving you a
realistic picture and not just making
stuff artificially look better than it
actually is the big cost to doing web
assembly is that your application will
get bigger and therefore take longer to
download and start so let's talk about
application sizes on webassembly
if you've got a really small application
like satellite simulator which hardly
does anything it's tiny when you do a
release publish on.net 6. that's 1.1
megabytes which is a really great
improvement compared with what we had
on.net 5. we've cut kind of almost 40
off that and that is just because we are
now stripping out a lot more code or
we're capable of stripping out more code
if you turn on the right flags but if
you publish that with aot that's going
to go up to 2.8 megabytes because aot
code just has a lot more stuff in it
that's all you know pre-optimized and
baked into it
right if you have a more middling sized
app such as the default app that comes
out of the project template that by
default is a two megabyte thing when you
publish it down slightly from net five
but not down as much because we don't
turn on all the code stripping by
default
when you do an aot build that's going to
double to four megabytes
okay and what about a large application
because obviously people do build large
applications and we need to think about
that
well
manufacturing hub is an example of that
and you might be thinking no no it's not
a large application because that's just
a demo you built it in like a week or
something that is not a large app but
actually it is a large app because
the size of your application is largely
determined by the size of your
dependencies if you've got a load of big
heavy dependencies then your app is
going to be big and heavy sorry but
there's no other way around it and
manufacturing hub uses ef core which is
absolutely not optimized for code
stripping on.net 6. now we might do some
optimizations for that in dot 7 but we
haven't in dot net 6. so if you depend
on that your app is at least going to be
about five and a half megabytes and if
you do an aot build it's going to be a
pretty scary 15 megabytes
all right so what can we say about that
well i would say
i would not recommend aot compiling the
manufacturing hub app because what's the
point all the heavy lifting is happening
inside sqlite there anyway which is
already itself aot compiled the net code
doesn't really even break a sweat so
what's the point making it three times
bigger when you won't have any impact on
the speed
whereas for the satellite simulator i
absolutely would ait compile that is
critical for the the nature of the
application that you want that so you
need to decide for yourself in your
application is this trade-off the right
one for me and sometimes it will be
sometimes it won't be
okay
so
that is a lot of stuff about blazer and
hopefully that gives you a sense of some
of the stuff that's changed in dot net
six some new opportunities that are
there for you
i would like to spend the remaining part
of this talk
uh covering something that's not
actually even about blazer which like
can you imagine that something that's
not even related to blazer
and i want to think about a little bit
webassembly not used in a browser
because so far all the time we've ever
talked about running.net on webassembly
it's been about running inside browsers
that's where webassembly started it's
the obvious use case but there may be
cases to run it in non-browser
environments as well
and to understand why we need to think a
bit about what webassembly actually is
well webassembly is a bytecode format
like dot net bytecode or java bytecode
which is designed to run in a sandbox
virtual machine
originally in the browser for for your
security
and what can it actually do well the
only thing it can do natively is just
perform operations on its own memory so
it's got a buffer of memory and it can
twiddle the bits in it that's literally
all it can do by default which sounds
completely pointless and it would be if
you didn't have a way of calling
functions in it or having it call
functions back to you and that's why the
other part of what webassembly is is the
ability to import and export functions
that can be called there all right so
that's what webassembly is but what are
these functions that we would import and
wouldn't it be nice if there was a
standard set of import functions that we
could rely on being there
well that brings us to something called
wazi or webassembly system interface
which some of you may have heard of
hands up if you've ever heard of this
yeah relatively few actually probably
only five percent of people right so
that is a spec that goes back for about
two years now
and um it comes out of mozilla and what
this actually is is a set of standard
imports for web assembly that give
access to operating system platform like
features so if you wanted to do things
like file system access work with
network sockets work with timers that
kind of thing that's what wazi provides
now critically it's still about running
in a sandbox so even though that you
might be able to access these operating
system features you also might not be
you as the user of wazi module can
choose to opt in or out on a
per-function basis
which platform features are allowed into
that sandbox and it's not about running
in a browser anymore this is primarily
about server-side code okay so why on
earth would you want to run your
server-side code on wazi you can already
run it without washi so why do you want
to make your life more difficult well
the answer is this potentially solves
some interesting problems
so
firstly it can solve similar kinds of
problems that you can solve with
containerization docker and that kind of
thing so if something crashes within
your wazi environment it's not going to
affect anything else on that machine
it's very much limited to to that one
thing that's been affected
and in terms of data leaks well
are you using any third-party modules in
your code any third-party dependencies
from nougat or npm the answer is
obviously yes you are
how do you know if it's doing something
nefarious behind your back and
exfiltrating all your data over the
network to hackers well truth is you
probably don't know but if it's running
inside a wazi sandbox then for that
particular call you can limit it and say
hey i'm making this call now but it's
not allowed to access network it's not
allowed to access file system it's only
allowed to use a certain amount of
memory it's only got a certain amount of
cpu time and you know then that it's not
doing anything weird behind your back um
you know with the network however
okay
at the same time it's about retaining
performance webassembly has always been
about getting near native performance
and we can do even better on the server
than we can do in browsers because
there's time to do more pre-optimization
and finally it gives you a pretty
extreme portability even more than a
docker container because it's
independent of your cpu architecture
it's a truly portable single binary that
would work on any runtime okay so who's
behind all this well mozilla created the
wazi spec originally they originally
created webassembly itself so makes
sense but since then it's been largely
put forward and pushed forwards by the
by code alliance which is a group of
companies that you've probably heard of
some of them and these people are
working on advancing that spec and
standardizing it even more and
importantly they've been building some
wazi run times uh in which you can run
your modules on a server so there's wasm
time which is the high performance one
and the webassembly micro runtime which
is the more portable one that come out
of the bike code alliance but there's
also various third parties creating
wizzy runtimes as well uh that have got
different capabilities and and
performance characteristics
there's quite a bit of hype around this
uh as well
this guy who created docker suggests
that if you had existed back at that
time they wouldn't have bothered
creating docker and in fact
it's a fairly mainstream view i'd say
among a lot of people that wazzy could
well represent the next logical step in
the evolution of containerized
server-side computing because it gives
you some of those benefits of the same
benefits as docker but in an even more
lightweight and portable way
now
bad news for you though if you're a net
developer so sorry to break this awful
news to you but the dot net support for
webassembly does not work on wazi and to
explain why it's because when we compile
the dot net runtime to webassembly we do
so using this thing called m scriptin
fairly old goes back to the data back to
the beginning of webassembly and that
compiles the.net runtime so that when it
wants to use platform features like
files and network and so on it maps that
into javascript api calls which is fine
if you're in a browser but not fine if
you're not in a browser because there's
no javascript in general in a way
runtime you don't want that it's more
lightweight than that
so we need a different way of
running.net on webassembly and that
brings me to a little experiment that
i've been working on for the last few
weeks or so
that i want to show you and this is an
alternate way of compiling the dot net
runtime to webassembly using the wazi
sdk instead of m scripting that's based
on the llvm compiler 2 chain and what
that does is it creates a net runtime
that when it tries to use platform calls
it will not use javascript it will just
use the wazi system calls or other
features of your jobs of your yz runtime
now this is just an experiment there's
absolutely no uh specific plan or
commitment to make a product out of this
but i just want to give you a sense of
how this could be and what sort of thing
we could do with that so let's see it
shall we
okay so i want to run some dot net code
on wazi and i'm not going to run any
exciting
code it's going to be super basic stuff
just to illustrate the point it's not
about the code we're running it's about
how we're running it and to really
emphasize that the first thing we're
going to run is going to be pretty basic
i think you can see what that's going to
do okay so i want to run this in wazi
now and let's jump over to the console
here which is this one
and i'm just going to run that first
and that is actually running there you
can see it says hellofrom.net and that
is running on the wasa micro runtime one
of the runtimes created by the bytecode
alliance uh let me just prove that it
really is the code that you saw in vs
running so let me change it so let's say
the time is
date time dot now dot too long
time string okay cool and then i'm going
to recompile that and rerun that in the
wesley environment again so this time
you'll see it's going to say the time is
and it gives us the time if i run it
again it doesn't have to compile this
time it just you know says the time
the the interesting thing here is this
is just pure wazi stuff so it's going to
run in any of these runtimes and to
prove that let's use some other runtimes
shall we i've also got a runtime called
wasma which i i pretty uh was one of my
favorite ones um and i'm going to run
this thing.net.wasm this is the
netruntime compiled through the wazi sdk
and that is going to find our.net dlls
and execute them or at least it's going
to try to but it will actually fail on
this occasion if i run it you'll see we
get this error and it says failed to
load this.net app dll so why is that
well this illustrates an important
aspect of wazi by default everything is
locked down you can't even touch the
file system by default and i didn't opt
into giving this file system access so
it can't load and run my code
but what i can do is i can say uh let's
give it access to the current working
directory and when it runs this time it
will find the dll and it will execute it
and it's nice and fast okay that's good
what about another third-party wazey
runtime let's try wasm time that's a
different bytecode alliance one uses the
same command line arguments and when i
run that same thing it's going to work
great okay so we can run stuff that
prints to console awesome that's great
probably going to make billions out of
that good
um but could we do something more
interesting than that could we make a
web server because the most common uh
use case that people cite for wazi is
networked services so i've made this
little web server this is not using
asp.net core i probably could make
asp.net call work like this but i
haven't tried yet so this is just a
simple little thing that's going to
listen for different http requests and
give different output and let me just
run it first and then you can see it so
let's go
web server here we go
and this is going to run on wasm time
now sorry wasma again and that's
listening now
so i'll start this up in my browser and
you can see it's displaying the current
time there if i refresh it updates um is
it fast well i don't know let's have a
look at the network trays shall we uh if
i reload this a few times then you'll
see it's generally always gonna take
about three two three four milliseconds
which is exactly the same amount of time
that it would take to run something on
kestrel or nginx or something so there's
no particular overhead in doing this
okay right so we've got some basic.net
code running on wazzy and that's nice um
but the point of this is not just to run
the same kinds of code that we would
have run before if that's all you want
to do then just keep doing it in the
same way the point of wazi is to maybe
write applications in slightly different
ways and take advantage of it to do
different kinds of things and so to give
you an example just to you know give you
a sense of how things could be different
i want to take a quick look across the
wazi ecosystem
imagine that you look around a little
bit and you stumble across a few
projects because there's loads of
projects on wazi that are doing
interesting stuff and so as an example
of that there's this thing called
lunatic which is a slightly dubious name
for their project but what they're
trying to do there is create an erlang
level reliability for server-side web
applications using webassembly so what
they're doing is
within your application instead of just
running it as a single process like you
normally do it runs as tens hundreds or
hundreds of thousands of microprocessors
each one responsible for a separate bit
of the system and each one is separately
sandboxed it's got its own memory space
and its own set of permissions uh and
you know its own ability to restart
things if they break down
so if you were building a web service
for example then maybe maybe every http
request would run as an independent
microprocess and then you could
guarantee that you would never
accidentally leak state out of one
request into another and errors or you
know resource issues in one request
would never affect another one so let's
see if we can write a little bit of.net
code and have it run inside lunatic and
see if that actually works so i've got
yet another project down here which
is i've wrapped the
lunatic apis in some net code here so
you can see i've got this request
started event and i'm just going to
print out some html to the response
we'll look at that more in a moment but
let's just start running so we'll go to
here and we'll do make run again
all right so that's going to start
things up there and i'm going to go to
that in my web browser so that's around
here
right and you can see it says
hellofrom.net after one request and it
displays the current time well let's
have a look at the code for that
so you see it's saying hello after count
requests and count is actually a static
and it's going to increment on every
request so
if this was a normal net application on
asp.net core or something then you would
expect that that count would go up by
one on every request and if i reload in
the browser it'll say two requests three
requests and so on well let's see i'm
going to reload and you'll see that the
time changes but it still says one
request why is that why didn't update
this this value the answer is
it did update it but every single
request is running as its own
independent microprocessor which doesn't
share any memory space with the other
requests which means that things like
statics cannot leak out from one request
into another
now this is not really about being able
to use statics that's kind of a silly
example the more important thing is that
you can't leak any state and in fact you
can't leak any memory at all even if
you're trying to
whatever memory state is used within a
request can just be instantly discarded
at the end of that request and that
starts to change the rules of the game
in some interesting kind of ways so as
dot net developers we've believed for a
long time that
you know you have to minimize
allocations because you don't want to
trigger too much garbage collection and
you you have to minimize thread blocking
because that's expensive but in this
kind of environment actually you can
allocate all you like it literally makes
no difference because we're just going
to atomically discard it all at the end
of the request i've actually turned
garbage collection off for these
requests because it literally would not
do anything anyway and in terms of
thread blocking well you can block all
you like because these aren't operating
system threads these are just
lightweight webassembly microprocessors
you can block them it's completely free
like literally doesn't make a difference
so just block if you want to it's fine
and then as another illustration of that
let's think about memory allocation
now i've set up a policy within the
system that each request is only allowed
to use a few megabytes of memory in
total and if i go to this url here it's
going to try and allocate 10 megabytes
which will exceed that memory budget so
what will happen let's find out i'll go
to allocate and you'll see it says out
of memory well my laptop is not out of
memory and the web server is not out of
memory the thing that's out of memory is
this individual request that's not
something you would normally be able to
do because normally you can't say which
memory belongs to which request but when
they're in separate microprocessors you
can and so we can impose budgets on
things like memory and cpu time we could
have diagnostics that say hey this
request uses more memory than this other
request and that kind of thing and this
really creates a new interesting set of
possibilities for how you could write
web applications that are potentially
simpler whilst also being safer and
equally performant as before
okay so
just to emphasize i'm not in any way
suggesting that we're literally going to
like ship something with lunatic i don't
even know who creates this thing i'm not
endorsing it in the slides i'm just
giving it as an example of the fact we
can we can take stuff out of the wazi
ecosystem or you can and build something
interesting with that
if we can run in this kind of way
so
that is all we're going to have time for
in this talk uh to recap we looked at
some of the new features on blazer on
net six uh we hopefully gave you a sense
that you could do some new kinds of app
features with that we looked at the
performance changes where they're aot
compilation and we looked at this
slightly uh wild world of wazi and how
you could do something cool with that
maybe in the future so if you want some
of the code from this talk you can go to
this github repo there that i've set up
and you can get the blaze orbital
application and all the related parts
the wazi stuff is not uh publicly
available just yet but i'll you know
we'll see about getting permission to
publish that but for now you can get
blaze orbital and play with that and
that's all we have time for so i hope
that's been fun and useful for you and i
hope that you have a really good rest of
conference uh remember to evaluate as
you go out and uh have a super day thank
you